congressman Bernie Sanders independent
from Vermont where does the United
States stand after one week of war with
Iraq let's perhaps the first problem
that we have to talk about is that we
don't know and one of the reasons that
we don't know is there has been in this
Wars you know an unparalleled degree of
censorship that the government is now
imposing upon reporters and I have a
real concern with that it goes without
saying that it is imperative that the
media not expose American soldiers the
loss of life through their reporting but
on the other hand we happen not to be
the government of Iraq or Saudi Arabia
we are a democratic society and in a
democratic society that people have to
know what is going on on the most
important issues facing them certainly
this war is one of the most important
things that's happened in this country
in decades so I have a deep concern that
we don't have a whole lot of information
for example one of the issues that has
not been talked about is the number of
civilians in Iraq who might have been
killed my guess is that the United
States government is attempting to hit
military targets and governmental
targets but given the enormous amount of
bombardment I cannot help but believe
that when we're talking about ten or
twelve thousand sorties that you're
talking about large numbers of civilians
who have been killed so to answer your
question I don't know I think for those
people who felt in the beginning that
this would be a very quick three-day
walk clearly that's not going to be the
case I I think right now probably the
issue of the moment is President Bush
contemplating fulfilling the resolution
of the United Nations which as you know
was getting Saddam Hussein in Iraq out
of Kuwait or has the mission of this
entire war effort changed so that we're
now attempting to go into Iraq destroy
the political infrastructure of Saddam
Hussein if the latter is the case and it
appears that that decision may have been
made by the president are we as a people
in agreement that that should be the
mission what are the costs attached to
that
goal the other day I was talking to a
couple of former military experts they
made the estimate that if the United
States wants to dislodge Saddam Hussein
from Baghdad they are estimating that it
will cost us forty thousand casualties
including ten thousand dead okay what
are the implications of that what are
the long-term results of the United
States now occupying a Baghdad in end
Iraq in the midst of fierce Arab
nationalism is that a position that we
want to be so I wish I could tell you
more but I can't where do you stand on
the use of force in fulfilling US policy
well I'll tell you and I think we have
all got to be very clear about this what
is happening at this moment is a
terrible terrible disaster for Humanity
no ifs buts and maybes about it one sees
one thinks about the children of our
country in the world watching missiles
being logged from one country to the
other the nightmares the fears that are
developing the nationalism hysteria that
is being developing all over the world
the contempt for life that we're seeing
all over the world these are very very
terrible times two major setback to the
United Nations my own feeling my very
strong belief was that given the reality
that the entire virtually the entire
world and the United Nations was united
against a two-bit fascist dictator like
Saddam Hussein I refuse to believe
refuse to believe today that that crisis
could not have been resolved without
this terrible war that we're seeing
right now that's what I believe and I
think unfortunately almost from the very
beginning President Bush was determined
to use military force rather than
diplomacy and I regret that very much I
think given the reality that were in the
war right now what I feel is that we've
got to do two things I think first of
all now that American men and women are
placing their lives on the line and are
in terrible danger clearly everybody has
got to support our men and women in in
the Armed Forces and their families back
home and in fact some of us in the
Congress and
working on a bill to make sure that
families back home whose husbands and
wives are in the army received the
financial support that they need second
of all I think that given the fact that
i know i'm amazed people disagree with
me on this but you know we do happen to
be a democracy we have not yet result we
given the president of the united states
alone all responsibility for everything
and this whole process I think the
Congress has abdicated a lot of its
responsibilities I know the president in
a war is the commander-in-chief you
can't have 535 people running the army I
accept that but the debate still has got
to continue as to what our goals are and
how we can resolve this jara with as
little loss of life as possible there's
already been terrible loss of life where
do we go from here is to try to resolve
it with as little loss of life as
possible my own honest view at this
point I think there are many who would
disagree with me is that if there is a
possibility and I'm not saying that
there is I really am NOT saying that
there is I no inside information to
believe that this is a possibility but
if it is possible but after the terrible
battering that Saddam Hussein in Iraq
and the people of Iraq have received
over the last week if there could be a
short ceasefire if you can have the Arab
League in the United Nations quickly
negotiating the withdrawal of iraq from
kuwait and if that could mean that we're
not going to be looking at the loss of
tens and tens or tens of thousands of
American casualties that's something
that I could accept but that's coming
from good evening from Washington we're
joined for the next 40 minutes or so by
congressman Bernie Sanders he's an
independent from Vermont and represents
the entire state he was recently elected
and he is a member of the Budget
Committee is that correct banking and
finance banking and finance previously
he was a college professor at harvard
university and hamilton college he was
the mayor of Burlington Vermont from
1981 to 1989 and he is a graduate of the
union of the University of Chicago we
will go to your phone calls very shortly
you'll see the numbers on the bottom of
your screen and just a reminder about
our 30 day policy if you have called us
in the last month please refrain from
doing so this evening but we will get to
your calls very soon congressman
obviously as someone who
is serving in his first month in
Congress in a very long month let me
tell you that and you probably didn't
anticipate that this would be the major
focus in this month what is the mood in
Congress if you can assess it after a
few weeks as far as other issues on the
agenda that's that's another point Kathy
that I wanted to touch on a little bit
when we look at this whole war and we
can analyze the war unto itself it has
to in my view we looked at within the
context of what's going on in our own
country today in my view and I speak of
course only for myself the problems
facing this nation are enormous are
enormous and I have the fear that at
least for some people to tell you the
truth and this may be cynical maybe i'm
wrong but for some people in some ways
despite the horror of one the pain of
war dealing with a war is easier than
dealing with a three trillion dollar
national debt a 400 billion dollar
deficit the collapse of our health care
system is in very terrible shape and i
came here pledging the people of my
state to fight for a national health
care system our educational system is
clearly in ruin in very difficult shape
twenty-five percent of our kids are
dropping out of school economically
industrially we are becoming rapidly a
second-rate nation every day Japan
Germany you can't pick up the paper
without seeing Japanese buying another
American concern and our kids are
flipping hamburgers and McDonald's okay
the problems facing the country the
mayor's are right here in Washington as
you know now city after City whether
it's Philadelphia or other cities facing
bankruptcy the drug problem I don't want
to bore the listeners because i'm sure
that are familiar with the problems and
it pains me very very much and angers me
very much that the Congress instead of
dealing with these problems which are
very complex very difficult they are
completely on the back burner no one
could even begin to address it the
mayor's are now coming into washing and
then they saying our cities are falling
apart what can you do for us the
congressman smile and say are you
kidding we're spending fifty we got
three trillion dollar debt the largest
deficit in our history and we're now
spending 50 100 billion dollars on this
war getting health care elderly people
in my own state of Vermont cannot afford
health care they cut back on Medicare so
one of the spin impact
X of this whole war is that we are not
dealing with the enormous problems
facing this country and that upsets me
very much that was another reason I
opposed I'll getting involved in this
100 much has been made of the fact that
you're an independent the only
independent in the house thus far how is
that working out for you it's working
out fine I was promised by the
Democratic leadership and is you know of
course the Democrats control the
Congress the day would treat me in terms
of committee assignments in the same
manner that they treat their their own
people and in turn i attempted not to
get into the democratic caucus and the
democrats have kept their word on that
and speak of foley and others have been
very fair about that i've gotten the
committee selections that I chose
banking and finance and is a minor
committee government operations clearly
my politics are different than many
people have been extremely polite and
there have been a group of 20 or 30 of
the progressive members of the
Democratic Party that I've been working
with and enjoying their row their
participation in with me when you say
your politics are very different what do
you mean by that well by definition
being an independent and being a
progressive and in my home city of
burlington vermont we are the only
strong three party city in the united
states of america my predecessor is now
the mayor progressive we have had a
plurality on our city council you know
vermont is the only state than many many
years that has voted for somebody
outside of the two-party system I am NOT
a believer that either the democratic or
republican party's given their views are
capable of dealing with many of the
enormous problems facing our country I
fear that both parties have been
captured to a large degree by big
corporate money by wealthy people and
that the class issues the issues of who
owns this country who controls this
country how does it happen that ninety
six percent of incumbents get reelected
why is it that that we have by far the
lowest voter turnout of any nation on
earth so many poor people in the United
States don't flow many working people
don't vote our standard of living as a
people is declining corporations of
shutting down factories taking them to
the third world where they're paying
people slave labor there were one of two
industrialized nations in the world
without national health care in other
words the problems are in
enormous we don't see the political
leadership to my mind in either of the
political parties to begin addressing
those problems I'm distressed for
example in terms of this whole Persian
Gulf stuff to my mind the Congress
abdicated its responsibility in this
debate from day one they should have
been there from day one debating the
future of the United States in terms of
the Middle East the long-term impact of
what we're doing on the Middle East and
I am outraged to be honest with you at
the president's attitude from the
beginning where he said you know what I
am the commander in chief but Congress
wants to come along and support me
that's fine but i don't need the
Congress's support to go to war which is
absolutely in violation of the
constitution of the united states that
was it turned out the Congress two days
before the war did give him his what I
did not majority the members day so what
he is doing now while I strongly
disagree with it clearly is not
unconstitutional but the attitude of a
president who says I will take this
country into war Congress you want to
come along not it's none of my business
I'm going to do it and I'll tell you
something given my two weeks although it
seems like two years already that I've
been in the Congress it's been a very
painful two weeks not just for me I
think every member of the Congress one
thing that I do have to tell you is I
had not realized the what's the word
that I want almost the impotence of the
Congress in general is an institution it
is not an important institution
virtually it is the White House itself
which informs the Congress of what is
going to happen despite the fact that
the Democrats controlled both houses
there is not an alternative agenda on
all of the important issues using many
Democrats going over to the Republican
side there's not a clarity of debate
people don't really see debate and two
sides of the story more or less you see
you know kind of 11 position and I think
if those people you know in Vermont that
we border on Canada for example of
course many of us are familiar with the
New Democratic Party in Canada which is
a social democratic party and I think we
do need to see the creation of a new
political party based on working people
the unions environmentalists peace
activists women minority people who
really a feeling out of the picture we
are the majority of the people and I
don't think we have much of a voice in
government let's hear from our viewers
east lansing michigan good evening
good afternoon senator you said
everything so wonderful is that's what
I'm sitting here thinking to live almost
lost where the door thing I'd like you
to do I'd like you to take a senator
phil gramm up to your part of the
country in TN and teach him some manners
and teach them some political science
thank you thank you for your kind of
moss thanks for the call Michigan go
ahead please call her yeah tacoma
washington I got a couple of things I'd
like to say one are you prepared for I'm
a Vietnam veteran I am preparing to go
to Saudi Arabia are you prepared when
you back down and decide to destroy the
morale of the military are you prepared
for an uprising of the military because
we're not going to take it again we're
not going to let you stab us in the back
that's the first thing then a second
thing I think it's a rather feeble
argument about your body bags when you
advocate trash bags for unborn babies I
will not give that the question of
dignity of the response i will not
response to you know the word stabbed in
the back you remember if i came from
that was Hitlerian that was how Nazism
developed in World War two I am fighting
his best I can for the best interest of
this country and for the men and women
in the Armed Forces I believe and have
believed from the beginning that Saddam
Hussein who is a very vicious dictator
must be defeated he must withdraw from
Kuwait and our goal is to accomplish
that with minimum loss of life and for
people in a democracy to be saying and
that by the way this is backhaul
represents one of the deep concerns that
I have about this whole debate that if
somehow one disagrees with the President
of the United States well by the way
three weeks ago was telling us that the
Constitution really didn't mean terribly
much to him that one is disloyal now I
am not disloyal I'm very loyal and
patriotic American who loves this
country quite as much as anybody else
and my
concern now is to make sure that we
bring home as many of our men and women
alive as possible while we accomplish
our goals and in the process that we do
not kill thousands of innocent women and
children in Iraq as well and in fact
make something that I'm unpatriotic I'm
sorry I don't I don't feel that way
altamonte springs florida you're on
c-span thank you very much mr. Sanders I
would like to say that I think that
George Bush was caught between a rock
and a hard spot in August he had a son
meal that was involved in the SNL scam
which we don't see her very much about
even though they had this committee
meeting and heating and all of that and
then he was caught in between the budget
and suddenly Kuwait came up it seemed to
me he was being an overprotective father
and getting away from the budget issue
and then Dwight came along to rally the
country behind him which was fine I am
30 years maybe retired I fly my flag and
my yellow ribbon from my car antenna and
I support our troops overseas but i
think mr. bush underestimated today I'm
because I think what he did thought he
thought it was another Grenada and
another Panama and I think he was wrong
there and another thing I would like to
say is that the representative I think
was the senator from Illinois said that
she would support attacks after the war
is over or possibly now against run that
against that we the people would have to
pay well that would be fine but with all
the unemployment lines getting larger
and larger who is going to pay that tax
well you raised the madam very important
questions and I think what you are
talking about touched on a moment ago
what I was trying to suggest is that
what this war has done intentionally or
otherwise is the flecked attention from
the enormous problems facing this
country the S&L arm on the Banking
Committee and we're going to be hearing
a request for I'm not sure between 40
and 60 billion dollars more in order to
bail out the s and LS
the commercial banks are on the verge of
collapse we have a recession yep you
know the problems facing this nation are
enormous and our attention from that has
been clearly diverted from those
problems now the woman mentions I guess
the center I hadn't heard that comment
indicator I gather that he would support
a tax to pay for this war is not the
case you mentioned that may be a
possible one of the things that we have
to deal with is my friends we are a
virtually bankrupt country I mean it's
easy to laugh at the Soviet Union as we
see them disintegrate you know but we're
not doing so hot our selves we are a
virtually bankrupt nation three trillion
dollars in debt and now facing I think
it's a four hundred billion dollar
deficit the largest in our history now
where we going to come up with the 50 or
100 billion dollars or whatever this war
is going to cost well my own view on
that is that given the reality that in
the last ten years the richest people in
this country have become very very much
richer the wealthiest one percent of
seeing almost a doubling in their real
income while the middle class and the
poor have become in many ways poorer
given that reality I would support
attacks to pay for the war but attacks
on the wealthiest people in this country
who have become much wealthier I who
have also during the last decade enjoyed
very very significant tax breaks to the
tunes of hundreds of billions lost
certainly the middle class the working
people in the poor whose kids by the way
are in the Persian Gulf to a large
degree cannot be asked to pay more in
taxes especially as their economic
situation deteriorates Houston Texas
good evening yes I want to thank you see
expand for doing so good job and my
question is how come United they did not
do anything when Israelis attack Lebanon
and also rush in there as invaded
Afghanistan so many other problems rocky
detective on and they would even helping
the rock and my question is that and
also another question what does he think
about peace conference you know world
peace conference over Middle East some
Palestinian problem and also the
Israelis and the Arab problem
well the gentleman raises an important
point and I hope that our viewers
understand this and let me just give my
point of view there is no question in my
mind that Saddam Hussein is a very
vicious evil person that what he did to
Kuwait was illegal immoral and brutal
but having said that I hope that most of
our view is understand that Saddam
Hussein was the recipient of billions of
dollars of agricultural credits from the
United States government that the Bush
administration supported that effort up
until as I understand it one day before
the invasion of Kuwait so this man this
Hitler today was our wonderful ally six
months ago uh furthermore some of the
weaponry that Iraq has came to him via
major companies from the United States
Germany and other Western Europe
accompanies so I think the gentleman is
raising the question of how come our
attitude has changed so much and take
that a step further right now one of the
things that I am very distressed about
in this whole war thing is look at who
our allies are in this fight for quote
unquote freedom we are fighting
alongside mr. Assad from Syria mr. Assad
to the best of my knowledge is today
regarded by the United States government
as an international terrorist this man
is a vicious dictator who is in every
sense of the word equal to mr. Saddam
Hussein except this moment he's our ally
now maybe two years from now we're going
to be a war against Syria and mr. Assad
and we'll hear what a Hitler he is well
let me say it before that war begins
he's a Hitler today okay here's a
terrorist the government will tell us
that we are allied with the feudalistic
monarchies of Saudi Arabia and Kuwait
does that have anything to do with
freedom the gentleman made a point and
he said are we being inconsistent there
have been other outrages in the past and
it's true it's true should we send the
troops into the Soviet Union right now
because of what's going on in Eastern
Europe in the Baltic region I think not
it raises the question i think the
gentleman's question raises the issue
makes a sensible foreign policy for the
United States all we've prepared to go
to war every time that there is an
international outrage should we go to
war in El Salvador tomorrow because
there is a government there that in my
view is a neo-nazi government that is
responsible for the deaths of tens of
thousands of people of its own people
well we support that government in
Guatemala we support the death squad
type government so I think to reiterate
that the that the tragedy of Kuwait
could have been resolved in a
non-violent way we could have crushed
Saddam Hussein without military force I
don't know any magical answers now but I
think what we want to do is resolve that
crisis get them out of Kuwait with
minimum loss of life our next call comes
from vermont's montpelier you're on the
air uh congressman I have to tell you
that I am a gentleman who did not vote
for you and I do not approve of your
tactics so far in the Congress but I
have four questions for you first of all
after what you said about the Democrats
in Vermont which are among the most
liberal in the naturally a sudden about
the Democrats in Congress thought was a
nation and you have all the time to
answer after all you've said about them
aren't you ashamed of your dealings with
them my second question is after what
you've said in support of sweetie
socialism what do you think about the
collapse of that the institution in
Sweden where they're trying to remove
most of what they've done third of all
do you agree with harry hopkins that all
our problems can be answered by spending
and taxing the taxpayers of the United
States and lastly are you so naive that
you really believe that Sarah saddam
hussein can be removed by peaceful means
thank them first of all of course i did
not say one word in this program about
the democrats in Vermont most of them
who supported me in my campaign to
become four months congressman second of
all in terms of Swedish social democracy
of course Sweden has economic problems
so does the United States so does almost
every country on Earth but if you look
at Sweden you look at a country which
has a national health care system which
provides free health care to all of its
people you have unemployment of about
two or three percent you have pension
programs for their senior citizens that
our elderly could hardly believe you
have you know in our country now we're
talking about parental leave programs
where family members who have a baby
would be able to take off a certain
amount of time without without getting
any pay of course in Sweden people get I
think ninety percent of their salary
college education is free I'm not here
to suggest that Sweden is a utopia it
has its problems but in terms of health
care in terms of education in terms of
housing in terms of workers rights terms
of unemployment there is a lot that can
be learned from Sweden in terms of the
question of my a great tax-and-spend
liberal actually I am NOT in the general
menifee is from Montpelier Vermont knows
that I was mayor of Burlington for eight
years and in fact do not believe in
taxing and spending what I believe in
you know when you're maiya unlike being
president of the United States you have
to balance the budget and I did that
fade years what I do believe however is
that if you're going to raise revenue if
you need tax money and of course you
need to raise taxes to deal with social
problems whether its military or
education or roads or whatever you must
raise that money in a fair and equitable
manner and that means ask those people
who have the money who can best afford
to pay the taxes those people who are
wealthiest those people over the last
decade who have enjoyed huge tax breaks
they've got to stop paying their fair
share so the gentleman means do I want
to tax those people yeah I much prefer
to tax those people then I would the
middle class in the poor we're seeing in
decline in their standard of living in
terms of Saddam Hussein and my naive do
I think Saddam Hussein's a nice guy and
all we have to do is say Saddam pull out
I've never said that I think this is a
very vicious dictator I think he can be
brought to his heels however do strong
and this is maybe this discussion is
academic right now but he could have
been brought to his heels by strong
economic pressure this man was cut off
he had no revenue coming in because he
was not selling his oil his economy is
declining was declining significantly as
gross national product I declined by
forty or fifty percent no I don't think
he's a nice guy and I don't think words
can bring up
could can get him to move but I think
strong economic pressure and the United
Nations peacekeeping force enforcing
nine embargo making certain that he's
not expanding that could have done the
job in my view we have about 15 minutes
remaining for congressman Sanders and
our next call comes from Cincinnati yes
I'm going to take you away from the more
I want to ask you a question if you
heard the Appropriations that Israel
today at United States 40 billion
dollars and they need 10 million dollars
to replace their losses from people that
love their job not went in the service I
understand you're on the banking info
committee and you understand something
like this I'm going to heaven for now
this is gentleman is right I didn't know
it was 40 billion and I hadn't heard he
may be right i heard it was in the 20s
yeah that's right but let me tell you
something in order to put this coalition
together we have already forgave
forgiven Egypt seven billion dollars I
believe we have already given or
forgiven Israel seven billion dollars
okay we have also made deals with Turkey
and Syria to my understanding other
words to bring these people into the
coalition it is costing us tens and tens
of billions of dollars so i think when
you talk about this war those are some
of the issues the fact that it is
costing as so many tens of billions of
dollars the fact that japan and germany
who are far more dependent upon persian
gulf oil than we are it is our young men
and women whose lives are on the line
not the Germans not the Japanese and I
know there is a great concern in
Congress that these people are not
contributing their fair share but I
think when you talk about the war let's
remember to three million men are
Americans are sleeping out on the street
kids in this country cannot afford to go
to college millions of our people cannot
afford health care and we should be
thinking once again whether it is in the
best interest of this country to be
putting tens and tens of billions of
dollars into this war whether it's Egypt
Israel or just the military in general
Harbor City California here on the air
yes I wanted dead to the gentleman is in
mr. Sun des that yes we should give
man-made to this world not
not for yellow report but for something
what we save life and these are
anti-missile missiles if our people we
got over 200 million people in
population in the United State if
everybody will give all the ten ballot
will not have put them to poverty and
this will give for our country two
billion dollars and we can win this
world very fast and with saving right
because anti-missile missile is a really
saving light missile this is run in my
statement another question are you aware
of this that Soviet Union tells the eye
light today Saddam Hussein you know like
I'm sorry that the Soviet Union is
alloyed with yes Soviet Union is RA is
supporting is that the magnetron bag but
because still the Soviet are in order
they are like you know advisor like a
military advisers and Soviet now is
there they make this man come in return
yeah so maybe to him to put these ideas
that we don't see really what they are
doing and Middle East thank you for the
call harbor city okay uh I mean just to
give you the depth of the problem I
think the woman felt that 200 million
people putting in ten bucks apiece would
be 2 billion dollars two billion dollars
is probably a two billion dollars is an
enormous sum of money two billion
dollars is I understand that we keep the
war going for about three days right now
so the fact is that we as Americans are
already putting in many many tens of
billions of dollars into the war in
terms of the Soviet Union's relationship
to Iraq there is no question that in the
past they were closely allied with Iraq
they gave a rack a great deal of
military support everything that I have
red indicates that that is no longer the
case Burlington Vermont you're on the
air with your Congressman yes hello
Bernie hello mama I did vote for you a
matter of fact and i am enjoying seeing
you voice your opinion for the war
against the war I just would like to see
you support the troops a little
more you know it it gets kind of
confusing when you see these Congress
people go from one side of the forearm
right back to the other right after
President Bush pushes Congress through
pushes this whole issue right through
and then suddenly here we are in war
what you think can seriously escalate
this war into being a real problem with
Israel and could you tell me when can we
see it some accountability for the
government and what they are doing with
our money I'm a middle-class students
and I you know I'm here in Burlington
Vermont we're trying to make any ever e
day our unemployment is going you know
gangbusters and I'm just a little
worried and hopefully you know could you
tell me a little bit of what what you
see coming upon in this war and the
economic time okay let me let me deal
with the it's nice to hear somebody
we're small state but it's likes to hear
people calling in um first of all it is
difficult and I'm trying very hard to do
this and I and I don't know that it
always gets across and I and I could
understand why to distinguish my lack of
support for President Bush's policies
and my a hundred percent support for the
men and women who had nothing to do with
those policies who are putting their
lives on the line and as I mentioned
earlier among other things I am one of
the co-sponsors of a bill which would
try to ease the financial anxiety of we
know in Vermont that i'm sure all over
the country many of the families who
have their loved ones in the Persian
Gulf are seeing a significant decline in
their income maybe the military pay is
fifty percent of what these guys were
earning in civilian life I think that's
wrong many of the families are wondering
how they going to pay the mortgages
college tuition the automobile loans we
have a bill now that was generating some
support which would do away with that
gap so I intend to show my support for
the troops and the men and women in
every way that I can't they're my
friends and my neighbors but I think
it's important to distinguish that from
my feelings about a president bush in
terms of the accountability of what's
going on it almost takes us back to the
very first issue I think it's an
important issue maybe people might want
to call in and address this one we are a
democracy we are not Iraq and we're not
Saudi Arabia I think we have a right
to know what in fact is going on and I
think that the media correctly I've been
reading a number of articles and and a
lot of frustration on the part of the
media the media in this country I think
in this area is not irresponsible
they're not and they should not be
allowed to divulge information which
threatens American lies to the best of
my knowledge for example we may not you
know this has been regarded it will
looked at is that antiseptic well people
are not dying we don't see the bodies to
the best of my knowledge and I may be
wrong on this that I stand corrected if
somebody wants to do that you may not
see wounded American soldiers on
television because the Pentagon feels
that that might upset American people
well you know what if there's especially
if there's an invasion of Iraq they're
going to be tens of that perhaps tens of
thousands of wounded soldiers do we have
a right to see that I think we do so in
terms of accountability also there is a
movement afoot now in Congress in terms
of financial accountability to demand
how much this wart is costing and to get
I believe an estimate the every month on
it so I agree with the cola media
Pennsylvania good evening yes senator
you sound like Biden who voted against
the flag amendment and yet when he ran
for the Senate he had a burger
flag-waving behind him now as far as the
news men they want to know they would
they would die to know about the
American attack plant so he could put in
the newspapers on the air before the
people even heard about it another thing
you forget that Hitler bomb women and
children with his buzz bomb the same as
the dad is now bombing those poor
Israelites with his bomb so women and
children died there too I think you're
wrong as an independent like a good
Democrat okay I mean obviously what
Saddam Hussein is doing in terms of
lobbing bombs Scud missiles into Israel
is a hot okay but you know what we are
also bombing intensively Baghdad and I
have the feeling that when the truth
comes out and I do not believe this is
the the goal of the United States
government I I think they're really
trying quite hard with that and with our
sophisticated weaponry the pinpoint the
attacks but when you do 10,000 sorties
or more innocent women and children
are also going to be killed Portland
Oregon you're on c-span all right good
night good evening rather and
congratulations on your election Mr
Sanders and I congratulate the people of
your district Vermont for lightning
you're a wonderful new voice I've got to
say that I disagree with you very
preferably on your evaluation of this
situation and I think its characteristic
of the illiteracy of our age that we
would soundless up by confusing our
Latin prefixes the description of an
ideal is not a prescription for action
real world and when you say T we could
have done this and yet you're sure in a
nice world that would have been possible
now I know there's been a lot of
conversation about rhetorical overkill
about during Saddam Husein toy doll 7
but I know something about this and the
fact of the matter is they both come
from rice man towns they both have
pseudo intellectual backgrounds and they
will both absolutely determined to seize
power this is a psychopath also it is
said that there are many Saddam
Hussein's in this world that's not true
we can name them Adolph ever Joseph
Stalin Pol Pot idiom in it BL folks like
that and now Saddam Husein the
extraordinarily dangerous human being
and it has to do my one little plan on
this one before I guess my question I'm
sorry to take so long this is about
nation building as it was in Germany and
so it is in Iraq highly fragmented
country the same same background but my
question is basically this as a
congressman
you feel that the bathroom reasons that
you're getting are adequate for you to
allow allow yourself to make a competent
decision as to how the thing is going on
and whether or not the objectives are
clear enough because by now we know what
the problem is it used to be getting
them out of Kuwait now it's between
creasing with their that we might be
trying to get Saddam Hussein not a power
in a whack and I was just wondering how
things are going that way for you I hear
my impression is that that more than a
few congressmen would suggest that they
perhaps don't have as much information
as they would like to be able to make
intelligent decisions that they would
like to make Summit New Jersey you're on
the air array for Bernie Sanders I
didn't think there was anybody like you
and Congress I like to think I'm an
independent voter but unfortunately I
keep voting Republican all the time but
that last time was the last one I'll
never vote for George Bush of many
Republicans again I think they're all a
lot of liars I think there are a lot of
cheap shot artists Bush has made this
war a personal vendetta of his home he
didn't do anything about the Russians
when they killed them as major at the
checkpoint Germany he didn't do anything
they make an administration didn't know
anything about the GI you non comms that
were beat up also at the checkpoints
when Latvia Lithuania asked Bush for
help and the supporting of independence
he was afraid to make the wrong mistake
I think the man is absolutely a coward
to think that he can move forth 400,000
men 4,000 miles all on his own he's a
dictator basically and it's a shame you
know this is supposed to be a democracy
but it really isn't the war is being
fought for oil profits and for the
bankers every war before has always been
that way reaction well I think the point
obviously don't think this country
is a dictatorship but I am deeply
concerned that I don't think people are
appreciative of the lack of input and I
have to blame the Congress I don't
playing George was George Bush has been
pretty straightforward and I kind of
respect that but i think that the
congress to a large degree has abdicated
its responsibility in this whole area
and as i mentioned before certainly one
of the shocks that I've had since I've
been in Congress is how weak that
institution is in general we have time
for one last call North Adams
Massachusetts good evening hi I was
wondering how congressman Sanders if he
supports Israel and thinks that Israel
the concept is the correct concept and
also is he a socialist a lot of question
is yes i am a Democratic Socialist in
terms of Israel of course Israel has an
absolute right to exist my concern is
they given the what's happening in the
Persian Gulf we have lost our ability
now to begin the serious negotiations
that have to take place for a long term
settlement between Israel and the
Palestinian question and the needs of
the other countries but certainly Israel
has a right to exist the Palestinians
are entitled to justice and the United
States and the United Nations are going
to have to play a very active role to
try to bring about a lasting peace and
social justice within that very complex
part of the world do you think enough
effort is being undertaken to look at
what the Middle East will look like
after this war no i don't i think there
is probably very little long-term
thinking of what the repercussions of
this world would bring about how would
you approach it again I I have to tell
you I may be boring the viewers out
there I am very upset and very
frightened not only about this war but
the long-term effect for example I mean
if people think that it makes good sense
for the United States government to be
running a puppet regime in Iraq amidst
all of the Arab nationalism that exists
if you think there's no problem there
you're wrong I mean it's hard to say
what can happen because we don't know
what fully
the repercussions of what's happening on
right now I read on the front page of
the New York Times today for example
that in Egypt one of our allies the
masses of people are putting pressure on
on the President Mubarak because they
are outraged increasingly upset about
his identification with the United
States you know we may not see this too
much on our television sets but in the
Arab world they are not very happy about
what's happening and I think at the end
of this war it is going to take decades
to repair the damage they are brown
skinned people they are poor people and
they are seeing this tremendous
unleashing of military might against the
one of their own countries despite the
fact that this guy is a terrible
dictator I have no believe me i just i
wish i could tell you differently i have
no magical solutions well congressman
Bernie Sanders independent of Vermont
thanks for joining us tonight to our
viewers thank you for being with us
thank you for your calls and have a good
evening